how do you stay motivated and how do you
motivate people when they start to slack
now motivation is it's kind of a strange
word because it doesn't really mean what
we think it means we think it means that
we're fired up to do something we think
that it means we're eager and passionate
to make something happen
and we think that somehow we should just
be able to turn on that eagerness and
turn on that passion but we can't
because you just can't turn on passion
you can't just turn on the desire to
execute a task just doesn't work that
way and honestly that isn't even what
motivate means motivate doesn't mean to
yell and scream and encourage no to
motivate actually means to provide a
motive a reason why so to motivate
someone is to explain to them why
they're doing what they're doing how it
will help them where it'll take them why
they should continue to work in the
struggle and to fight and when you need
motivation yourself look for someone to
scream and yell don't look for someone
else to give you motivation look at you
look at yourself and remind yourself why
why you are doing what you are doing
remind yourself that this struggle this
temporary pain this fight this fight
that you're in this is what will make
you stronger and faster and smarter and
better and then with that motivation go
forward into the fray into the storm
into the heat of the battle where
victory is forged